I'm joined this week by tarik Fatah
tarik is a writer a broadcaster a
secularist and a liberal activist I
probably could think of a couple other
buzzwords you want to throw some more in
there for me me a bad Muslim and I was
going to let you say it I didn't want to
say it myself
it doesn't good ah bad as in good Muslim
all right well I'm really looking
forward to talking to you because
interestingly the way I've done this
show every few weeks suddenly I get a
burst of tweets people saying I have to
sit down with this person or that person
and about two weeks ago suddenly I was
getting a slew of tweets that I have to
talk to you and we had already connected
so so I'm glad that were able to take
some time to do this I'm glad I am my
network worked you know because as you
know I'm paid by Mossad and the Indian
intelligence and I told them you gotta
go out to David and get the two of us
connected yeah people think I'm paid by
the Mossad to I pretty sure yeah I'm
pretty sure I would have better better
furniture than all the IKEA stuff that I
have you you better keep that between
the two of us ah don't worry we're not
recording this first off I love what's
going on behind you with all those books
you're obviously a well-read man well
that's a bad thing you know if you are a
Muslim because it breaks down a whole
lot of barriers that are set around you
when you born in a Muslim household
especially in the last I would say 6070
years
oh that's century for that right up to
tables I would say for many years of
SLAM everybody wanted to open up the
books and then was the Islamic state of
Pakistan followed by you know preceded
by sally kingdom but they didn't have
money then and ever since then the very
notion of a Muslim critiquing Islam is
heresy the whole tradition of the 10th
century Muslim atheist or rationalist is
so
so far away that if you tell educated
Muslims today even postgraduate students
of Islam even non-muslim that the
culture of Islam was full of negating
God and then embracing him after
negating because the the essence of our
declaration of faith is that there is no
God
before we say there is a God who said
there is no god but God and you know
there's a button between its philosopher
philosophically what drew a lot of Arab
and Persian eight years into Islam
because it permitted them to do this
questioning and without the fear of
death yeah so I want to focus there for
just a second because I've seen you I've
seen you do talks on this and write
about this this idea that sort of the
the free thinking that we now don't
associate with Islam is actually a
pretty new occurrence you're saying in
the last 60 or 70 years can you can you
kind of distill that a little bit look
right up to the 1800s
we had a particularly dark era in which
let's put it this way 90% of Muslims
were illiterate still today 90% can't
speak Arabic 50% today are illiterate so
you can imagine the year 1800 but what
the Sultan said was Islam now if you go
back 1800 to till the turn of the first
millennium the year 1000 preceding that
at 200 years where literacy is booming
and people are thinking in their own
languages what happens is the next 800
years nobody knows anything about Islam
which makes them ok Muslims because they
have not read the some of the really
harsh racist rhetoric that comes that if
Netanya says now if you're a non Arab
Muslim and if you say you're equal to an
Arab you're sinning nobody knew that
so people were Muslims and they adapted
to the Indonesian of India Indian or the
Kazakh or the Turkish customs and then
came the colonial
yeah let's pause for just one second so
I think what you would say and I and
this is where I would be okay with
certain religion is that at that point
until the colonial era it was pretty
much okay right because people weren't
taking things very literally they sort
of didn't understand the doctrine in a
certain way and they then took the
customs of wherever they lived be it
Indonesia Turkey wherever else and then
that's how they live their lives
absolutely and then came the Brits and
the French and the Portuguese who
started translating the Islamic classics
into their own languages the fascinating
thing is even the Hindu Upanishads were
first got translated by a Muslim mughal
prince who by the way later got beheaded
but he took it to persian and fish and
then english so whole lot of these
things happening in the 17th 18th
century but when the europeans come all
these classics get translated into
french and english primarily summon
spanish as well and that translation
then come back to the elites of the
muslim world so the egyptians are the
indians and basically these were the two
sources of islam Egypt and India or Iran
to a certain degree and suddenly you got
half-baked
scholars who find the easiest thing let
me give an example the Quran is still
not in its chronological order so the
first word of the Quran is not the 1st
of the Quran and when the last word of
the Quran which is quite fascinating
says God says today I've completed my
religion for you that's it
99% of Sharia says oh these completed it
let me improve it right and it's not in
the Quran it's not the last word and so
you pull your hair and say who did this
stuff but you can't ask that question
because the opposing party is upset at
two things first is how dare this guy
who just looks like a normal fellow
asked me this question and
the anger comes when he does very rarely
she does realize my cart is talking
sense why doesn't the Koran start with
the first revelation of God which says
read and write God doesn't say preachin
pray write mean he doesn't even talk
about worshiping him in the first world
isn't go read and write because I
created you from a single you know so
it's fascinating but Rhea I think in a
worse situation today than ever before
well that's why I've spent so much time
talking about this and you know one of
the mantras of this show is trying to
separate people from ideas because there
are obviously hundreds of millions of
good Muslims that that practice whatever
religious thing they want that don't
want to hurt anybody I want to be as
part of Western society as much as
anybody else in our liberal and
proration society Raja what would a
villager in South India what does he
have to do with anything poor guy is
basically saying I wish there was rain
yeah my riot my rice crops going down
yeah doesn't give a damn what Osama bin
Laden is saying Isis thing however the
leadership of the Muslim community
around the world are not tied in to that
farmer they are tied in tune to this
notion that life on Earth is temporary
earth is a transit line we go to blow it
up and finally catch a transit flight to
paradise
it's now a debt cup and if you cannot
accept that there is no solution okay so
I know I know that a lot of people when
they hear you say that they're gonna say
well there's plenty of bad stuff in the
Old Testament there's plenty of bad
stuff in the New Testament if you looked
at them side-by-side the Quran might be
the least violent of all of them so how
do you how do you rationalize that
listen well the Christian the good
Christians on that they want to make
this world paradise okay Jesus is gonna
come make it beautiful right there is
concept of afterlife but not ask for the
destruction of human civilization I've
never met a Jew
sis I gotta do something about this
rotten stuff we've invented insulin
right I mean we have people in packs on
a PhD scholar just last week defying the
laws of gravity saying that this is
satanic these are not people who are
working-class ordinary you know janitors
or some disguise' PhD in physics yeah we
had a Nobel Prize winner who used to
believe in an amulet that would float
around in his car and he would pray
around that he's a dope that signs this
piece of paper is gonna protect me what
what do you make of someone that can be
in the science realm and then so
discount science for the unprovable you
know for the leap of faith for whatever
religion it is it goes most of our
scientists are not scientists because
they had a curiosity to discover science
the parents told them if you do
mathematics and engineering you'll get a
better job I mean when he's
straightforward no one wants to be a
philosopher ever didn't everyone you you
noticed why the Muslim Brotherhood is
filled with engineers they are honorable
sociology graduates if it wasn't brother
they're all engineers or doctors that's
the Gateway to a good income an
upper-middle class they are interested
in treating people there's no desire I
wish I could heal you no paralysis
no yeah so when you talk about the the
leadership of the Muslim world at least
since you know let's say for the last 70
years or so I assume you're mostly
talking about sort of the Sunni Wahhabi
ISM that's coming out of Saudi Arabia is
that is that really the leadership right
now of the sort of extreme side of this
let me let me give you an example who
are the people who created the first
Islamic state which is practicing
they're not the Sunni Muslims there were
these miley's they were the Ahmadiyya
Muslims which the West receives ah they
smileys and the Ahmadiyya Muslims
they're very liberal
it was the anima DS who said ah let us
create a country where we could
experiment the other con him
both was sitting in India divided Bengal
between East Bengal and West Bengal in
1905 these guys each one of them no
matter what the sector's had the view of
the 12th century to be brought into the
21st did her it would rearrange the
digits ah boom we pray to God God's
gonna intervene camels come forth salt
stones these white people Christian Jews
and atheists ah we'll deal with them he
didn't turn out that way Pakistan was
created
imagine the territory that is today
Pakistan mr. West avoids to discuss at
its own peril yeah nobody wanted
Pakistan there the Pakistan that people
wanted a night a change its name to
Bangladesh in 1971
that's a secular country that government
is fighting the Islamists and no one
seems to put together anything because
I'll tell you something I think West and
Israel stop at the iran/iraq four-letter
words anything east of that is
multi-headed God's fire dragons exotic
gore Bali
nobody's concern about factions 200
nukes imagine I think there is a failure
of the European and North American
intellectual academic class to say what
is the primary problem here yeah so so I
love that you're bringing that up
because I just watched your TED talk
yesterday I watched it on YouTube and I
thought it was really fascinating and I
know that you're a student of history
and not only a student of history but
you literally lived this history you
were born I think in 1949 so you were
born basically you were a baby as
Pakistan was a baby you were you were
born in Pakistan um but in your table
you face a very different way so I want
I want to talk about a little bit about
your childhood
but first nobody seems to know about
this part of the world you know all the
time on this show and if you watch CNN
or fox or whatever they talk about the
Middle East all the time they people
understand British partition plan
something and he might not like it are
you yes no please we are just not pretty
enough like fair Turks Arabs we
brown-skinned ha I kill you east of the
Himalayas the exotica starts the
[ __ ]
you know the dragon the Hindu god the
sufi saint standing on one leg on top of
a mountaintop Orientalism has destroyed
the ability of the Western liberal than
the Christian churches know us better
the Catholic Church knows us better the
Avenger Kurds knows better because they
come down in the work I went to Catholic
school I have immense debt to pay to my
father's who never made me feel I was
not a Muslim and in deep poverty of a
family never made me feel I was poor I'd
realize 20 years later that my principal
father master is gone
I don't know where he is he paid my
school fees out of his own pocket
well now dad an American diplomat
wouldn't know the the Americans
primarily created wax on with the
British primarily the British I would
say as a buffer zone between the USSR
and India neither white academics want
to know that nor the Indians know that
parson has never existed and will not
exist so not from him yes oh wait let's
just stop there because it's a lot of
information and because I know people
don't focus on this part of the world I
tried it I try to give it to them in the
simplest terms so basically the the
British controlled that area and then in
1947 then India became a sovereign
nation right and Pakistan became a
sovereign nation but what you're saying
is there was no sort of justification
for Pakistan to exist as a as a
nation-state sort of into in a minute
I'll explain that yeah Berlin fell to
the Red Army Churchill panicked they had
tried to reach to get Germany to
surrender the Wehrmacht was heading west
to surrender to the advancing American
British
but the Red Army had suffered enough
they took Berlin and took half of
Germany do you know on the deja Berlin
fell Churchill ordered an instant
inquiry of British interests in the
Indian Ocean and in British India he
wasn't worried about Europe that had
gone from his and he was concerned
because the Soviets had entered Iran
they had set up a state there a Kurdish
an Azeri state
he asked the Indian National Congress Oh
mr. Gandhi and Nehru will you allow us
to set up a base in Northwest India to
counter the Red Army the Indian said now
they were pretty close with the
Communists and then he went to the
Muslim League these guys said no problem
right how much money will you give and
it's after 1945 within two years of the
holocaust that an entire new country
comes India gets cut off from the Soviet
Union Iran gets cut off from India and
the Americans set up a base in northern
Pakistan from where the garriepowers
flew and those then shut down of a
Soviet Union now that connection in the
West is not made that all of this is so
intertwined that unless we read out all
of this oh my god
this was a mistake that we made and
somehow we go to stop giving billions of
dollars every year to the Pakistanis
well then kill Americans Yeah right so
ok so there there's a lot there there's
a lot there so let's try to unpack it a
little bit so you so first off I hope
this question is in somehow offensive or
sign but so you know you because you
were born in Pakistan do you consider
yourself Pakistani or Indian because it
really because I think this is your
point is that it makes no difference in
a weird way and I think there is no such
thing as a Pakistan it's an acronym you
know to countries that are created on
the basis of an acronym which means a
based on a certain value the United
States of America which is USA and
Pakistan which is Punjab Afghan
Balochistan and sin you know put this
together
one is based on its constitution the
First Amendment the Bill of Rights the
everything that today the rest of the
world aspires to you guys did it in 1767
right right my right on that boy that
was good we got it fixed we guys came up
and said I am to kill you infidel they
started on the theory a racist notion of
the two-nation theory which says Hindus
are inferior than Muslims we have a
right as a Muslim minority to have an
apartheid state under which a billion a
thousand million Hindus will be ruled by
said one hundred million Muslims that's
outrageous something as offensive as
that cannot sustain or create goodwill
or good people and evidence shows that
even the best of Pakistani cannot be
weaned out of his hatred of the Jew the
Hindu whether whether these people are
living in the United States for 50 years
or 100 years that couple that killed
people in San Bernardino you don't have
that many Arab terrorists in the United
States as many as you have
Pakistani born hmm even Major Nidal the
day he killed he was reading a Pakistani
attire yeah
you look at the New York a bomber why is
it that a Daniel Pearl has to be killed
in Pakistan by a Pakistani balling the
United Kingdom from one of the most
prestigious institutes in the world
it's that frame of mind that says I am
supreme I'm not an Arab I'm not a Turk
I'm not an Indian or nothing I'm an
empty bag you can fill it with hate seal
it tight wherever you keep it I'll
contaminate that place is that bad yeah
so basically what you're saying is
because this state was not born out of
an F
Anisa tea in and of itself it's sort
it's sort of a void and then can be
filled with whatever ideology fits and
actually that then does make sense to
our the strange relationship that the
United States has with Pakistan where we
know that they're doing a lot of bad
stuff we know the terrorism is coming
out of there we're drone striking people
there they were hiding bin Laden it's
unclear if we knew we went into the
attack there so the relationship is is
insanely complex right it is the
Americans who Americans have him poor
Americans nobody ever says poor
Americans their night they've been
suckered into of the last seventy years
they take your money and kill you and
you give them some more because inherent
in the American attitude I'm a lefty I
have been enough demonstrations out of
an American consulate saying hey oh you
know George Bush cut it off but what
Fatali out like your value is based on
goodness of the essentially quality of
human beings you destroyed a slavery you
don't have a problem admitting you don't
have a problem admitting that you were
once anti-semitic but you have created
some of the most outspoken Jewish people
the blacks in your country today my
goodness the sulfur Kenyan immigrants
president of a country it's not going to
happen in Pakistan in a million years
he's black can you imagine a black
president of China Americans don't know
but it's so essentially moral about the
existence and the use that isn't that
many things bad I leave that aside sure
you get fooled by some of the most
crooked evil people who consider
themselves as holy
you